el partido de los republicanos partido
de derecha está realizando finalmente
después del último debate ayer su
elección no es cierto de un precandidato
electoral es una elección en línea en la
que están llamados 140.000 adherentes
del partido raúl lo que es un 77% más
que en septiembre hay que decir que este
partido hizo toda una campaña de
adhesión y está muy contento en general
todos los candidatos se unieron pues
mucha gente ha vuelto al partido
recordemos que ellos perdieron muchos
votos por el presidente emmanuel macrón
por un lado de las pasadas elecciones
después además del escándalo fillón y
también mucha gente que se fue a la
extrema derecha como decía es una
elección online que se realiza hoy y
mañana la primera vuelta y si ninguno
alcanza más del 50 por ciento se hará
una segunda vuelta en todo caso habrá
candidato seguro el sábado a las dos de
la tarde de raúl hoy en la mañana
solamente ya había más de un 20% de
participación lo que es muy bueno y hay
cinco candidatos de los que ya hemos
hablado otras veces en directo parís hoy
vamos a hablar de los tres favoritos el
primero de ellos es michel barnier que
es el negociador del break sheet
el nombre y también antiguo comisario
europeo es una persona que tiene a su
favor una carrera internacional una
persona muy moderada es el más mayor
también el más viejo hay que decirlo
raúl pero se ha vuelto muy muy radical
durante esta precampaña de los
republicanos con medidas como por
ejemplo suspender la ley migratoria
europea como hacer una moratoria
migratoria europea para do francia o por
ejemplo restablecer nuevamente el
servicio militar obligatorio no le ha
ido bien además en los debates si no
tenemos a una mujer la presidenta de la
región tilde fons que es donde está a
parís balear y pp es también muy dura en
los temas migratorios y de seguridad
recordemos son los temas fuertes de la
derecha migración seguridad e identidad
pero ella dice que es la candidata de
las ideas y recordemos hace poco ya
decía que iba a ser del abandono escolar
su caballo de batalla de este quinquenio
y finalmente ya viajan que es el
presidente de la región de los norte de
francia a los altos de francia él es el
favorito de las encuestas del mejor
parado para enfrentar a cualquier otro
candidato que podría ser ejemplo marine
lepén manuel macro el tiene a su favor
que dentro de todo es como el candidato
más social de la derecha social más
moderado pero también se ha puesto
radical durante los debates sobre todo
el decía bueno hay que favorecer la
emigración pero la que sea útil para
francia raúl en general balear y píxeles
y bertrán recordemos ellos dejaron el
partido durante algún tiempo y hace poco
que volvieron para esta primaria
justamente por eso eso es un punto a
favor de wagner